and we are following breaking news in
the fight against Isis in Syria us back
Syrian forces leading the offensive
celebrated as hundreds of militants
surrendered overnight our Charlie
d'Agata is on the front lines of the
battle he's reported on for more than
two months for the last slice of
territory held by Isis Charlie sent us
this report from eastern Syria on the
fight for Vagos military commanders say
fighting continues today but they've now
got the remaining Isis militants pinned
back against the Euphrates River after
troops here breached that final Isis
encampment yesterday covered in dust and
exhausted from brutal frontline fighting
these us back soon democratic forces by
the energy to dance does today feel like
victory for you yes or at least it feels
like they're close after an endless line
of Isis fighters surrendered from
buguese the very last scrap of territory
under the militant groups control but
they're not giving up without a fight
Isis video shot from inside the camp
shows militants spraying gunfire in
every direction the last bid to halt the
progress of advancing troops but the
video also included what amounted to an
Isis admission of defeat in bougas we
did everything we could
this fighter says the dying so-called
Caliphate is drawing its last breath and
that is reason enough to celebrate the
SDF has warned this morning that there
is still fighting to be done that
they're encountering what they're
calling pockets of resistance from Isis
militants who seemed determined to fight
until the very end for CBS this morning
Charlie d'Agata in eastern Syria